yes
this is a street in new york
harlem
my name is kirk douglas
these are the wide open spaces of
california
this is a section called watts
in the city of los angeles
my name is gregory peck
los angeles has a music center
and a ghetto
this city has the largest cultural
center in the world
and the biggest ghetto
now civic pride doesn't include boasting
about slums but we have them and they're
getting bigger
here
washington chicago los angeles all over
this land remember that first day back
at school when the teacher asked you to
write how i spent my summer
i went to summer camp my family has a
cabin in the mountains
i'll help my father at the store
i wonder what these kids are right yeah
i know some people don't care they say
it's a shame or what's it gotta do with
me
but many we hope will say
how can i help they know that harlem and
watts and chicago
and newark
and detroit
and memphis
diminish
all of us are we going to let the kids
of the day
live in the same despair tomorrow
the answer to that can be no if enough
of us say yes to these young people
initials y yes
can tell the story of the months ahead
youth employment
in summer would you like to work you're
going to school now
yeah but if you had a chance to work
this summer you if you had a chance to
get a job you wouldn't work yeah
yeah is it tough
you have any plans now you haven't
gotten have you got a job yet no not yet
huh
and if you want some summertime
employment who do you talk to is there
any bureau of high schools
are there many jobs for the kids
what about you
what are you going to do during the
summer
you want to go to puerto rico yeah you
got relatives in puerto rico
all right you'll have a good time well
listen you're all nice to let me come
over here and talk to you i don't know
that these kind of quick trips that
people in my
field of entertainment do can do very
much but i hope that out of this other
people will get a chance to know what's
happening in harlem
what the people are like and maybe they
could help a lot more than they're
helping now huh well thanks very much
the e in that yes stands for education
and entertainment too
employment education and entertainment
in the summer
time of greatest need
a time of boredom
and bitterness
idleness and frustration
these boys and girls feel shut out
raymond cruz what is this what does that
stand for this is the best pocket park
oh that's i would play basketball it's a
little place that's 123rd street between
third and lexington is a small
anti-poverty program that you have a lot
of those oh no this is the only vest
pocket park that has been built it seems
to be the first experimental park that
needs harlem and we're trying to uh set
up some programs for this community
we're trying to design programs to try
to help some of these people out here in
the ghettos we have problems with people
on welfare we have problems with people
in school receiving inadequate education
we have problems with
getting people jobs because many of
these students dropped out of school is
that a big problem getting a job there's
so many drug addicts out here people
just receive public welfare because i
think that's what we're trying to do to
try to do everything we can to try to
get jobs for kids during the summer this
is the problem that a lot of people
don't know what's going on in the ghetto
area they hear about it they see them in
movies but yet they don't know what's
really going on like you take a good
look at the buildings right now
buildings like this one here it doesn't
have no safety log these people really
have a lot of things in their mind they
don't they're not illiterate and
depressed and deprived the way people
downtown think they are lazy i must say
this yeah
there's a lot of things i didn't know
about i mean by you coming down here it
helps to attract people and help people
to to concentrate on you and if people
come around you and start talking about
the problems maybe people can be more
aware of what's going on
a voice from harlem says
give us a chance
can it be said
more eloquently
here in watts
i've heard this plea echoed many times
this echo of hope
must not be ignored
or neglected
or crushed
these young american citizens are a
crucial part of america's future
the odds have been stacked against us
now these kids need help they need your
help
and my help and they need it now
now that means jobs
drop out re-education
and proper recreation
now all over america
vice president humphreys yes program is
underway to make summer
1968 the best time yet in the lives of
millions of youngsters
right
you want to help
if you're a businessman
cooperate with the national alliance of
businessmen by giving employment and
training to deprived youngsters
if you're in a trade union
you can assist by opening up
apprenticeships for these young people
my industry entertainment wants to do
its part
and it's asking you to do yours
urge your school board to keep schools
open and productive during the summer
now if you're qualified in a skill or
art donate some of your time as a youth
instructor in a deprived neighborhood
almost any organization you belong to
can help
women's club
veterans post fraternal society
start your organization
moving forward today
ask your group to start a youth project
where it's needed most
and if you don't belong to a group then
call up volunteer yourself
this is not a call for charity
but a call for human involvement
that will enrich us all you know there's
only three letters in yes
but they can spell a whole new world for
these kids
yes
yes
yes
why don't you try saying yes
you'll be glad you did
this is gregory peck
from watts this is kirk douglas in
harlem and now in washington dc
the chairman of the yes program the vice
president of the united states hubert h
humphrey
well thank you kirk and greg and
my sincere appreciation to the entire
amusement and entertainment industry for
the help that you're giving these young
people
are really our greatest untapped natural
resource
now if we fail these young people now
they may fail us later on so we can't
afford to take that chance
they're anxious to show what they can do
they want work not charity that's what
they want and that's what we ought to
give them
we're asking you now to help hundreds of
thousands of our young americans to go
to work to learn and to earn
so start today let's call the mayor's
office and ask for the youth opportunity
coordinator
and see what you can do
to get a program going you'll not only
be helping your country you'll be
helping yourself
so uh young friends i'll tell you what
let's do let's tell america now to say
yes
yes
you